hey last week we had like one of the
most cringe-worthy moments on the show
where I can't even believe this happened
we got a voicemail which I thought was
asking me about the dating website
tinder and it was actually asking me
about tenure and I answered the entire
thing as if they were asking about the
dating website
totally cringe worthy let's listen back
to just a few seconds of it now knowing
as many people wrote in and said David
the guy wasn't asking about tinder he
was asking about 10 years take a listen
to this we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p let's
take a listen to the voicemail that came
in early this morning hi David I just
wanted to know what your thoughts on
Tingler is it's like if you believe if
it's a good thing or a bad thing whether
or not it helped students or hurts them
yeah just wanted to listen opinion thank
you
I don't think that tinder which is a
dating app is objectively good or bad
you always will hear people who take
very black and white positions example
meeting over the Internet simply not as
good as meeting people in person
so if he was asking about 10-year and I
figured students use tinder maybe I was
talking about that he was talking about
tenure okay so we should just deal with
that right now looking back at it it's
pretty funny because he does mention
students yeah yeah as well students
dating as opposed to meeting on campus
outed meeting online so listen there's
some obvious pros to tenure the
institution of tenure it does protect
teachers from being fired for political
reasons or non-work-related reasons it
prevents school districts from firing
experienced teachers who are now earning
more money to hire cheaper teachers who
are also less experienced and and not as
good for the learning environment
it protects teachers from being fired
for teaching unpopular stuff or
controversial stuff or or challenging
challenged curricula but of course you
have to also consider that it protects
teachers who are doing terrible jobs or
teachers who may be for example
violating certain standards but not so
much that it would be sort of exempt
from tenure protections you can make the
argument that tenure creates complacency
but I would argue against that because
teachers don't mostly get into teaching
and get the master's degree and
relatively low pay in most of the
country although in some places teacher
teachers make good money to just be
complacent they really it's a lot of
work to become a teacher they do it
because they want to teach you no I
don't think that's a strong argument
against tenure that's pretty good damage
control there you think I think maybe
you'll be able to recover from this
controversy big picture okay I think
that I but I believe not I think I
believe that the benefits of tenure
outweigh the costs mm-hmm I think there
are other ways to mitigate the possible
downsides of tenure and I think when we
when we consider what it is we're
looking to do in education tenure
provides some really important
protections for teachers that in the
long run benefit the students can tenure
be misused of course are they're free
riders anytime you have any form of
insurance and tenure is a form of
insurance right it's it's a job
insurance or a job guarantee or a job
protection for tenured teachers you will
always have people misusing that or or
who are free riding but I've not seen
evidence that the system needs to go so
I am for tinder and I am for tenure
although people can misuse either or
both and I've seen it done I know
college professors who are who are
misusing tinder but are tenured and you
know it works it's a free country but I
swipe right on both exactly what that
means I don't know but we will talk
about that after the show and off-camera
Pat thank you